hello everybody and welcome back to
another video today I'm going to show
you how you can use Chachi BT and
jupyter notebooks
[Music]
now I absolutely love using chat gbt
when I'm coding I usually just open up
the openai website type in my code into
chat EBT and then I copy and paste it
back but when I was using jupyter
notebooks I was hoping I could use chat
GPT in jupyter notebooks and just kind
of save time by going back and forth and
back and forth and I think I figured out
how to do that now full disclosure does
not need tutorial on how to do this I'm
not starting from scratch and building
it all out I'm just going to kind of
show you what I've done and how to do it
but I do it in two different ways the
first way is using chat gpt's API so I
just use my API key use it within the
cells in Jupiter notebooks and if I'm
being honest this is not the best way to
do that I'll show that to you in just a
little bit the second way you do it and
the way that I recommend it is this
extension that I found that integrates
into your Jupiter notebooks and it is
phenomenal I just started using it about
two weeks ago and I was like whoa this
is really really helpful it's basically
like having chat gbt with you there when
you're coding in jupyter notebooks it's
phenomenal and I think it's really
really helpful I just wanted to show
show it to you so let's jump onto my
screen we'll take a look and we'll see
how we can put chat gbt into your
Jupiter notebooks all right so the first
way that I want to show you how you can
use Chachi BT in jupyter notebooks is by
using the API key now you are not going
to use this API key because I will go
and delete it you can try it if you want
to I'll have that on my you know GitHub
where I post this so you can just copy
this and try that yourself but to
actually install this you need your own
API key so you just have to go to the
openai account API Keys create your own
API of course you know this does cost
money but I've used it quite a few times
and it's cost me like six cents so it's
crazy cheap but you go and you get your
API key you copy that and then you go
over here and we input it as our API key
we have this function that we created
and then we prompt it so we say prompt
what are the benefits of using renewable
energy and it gives us this output now
here's what I found about the API uh
really quickly is that when when you do
it like this you're using the API key
like this in your Jupiter notebook it's
extremely limited it's actually not
super even helpful I would just go into
Bing or chat GPT and use it there so if
I'm being honest this isn't the best way
to do it I would probably if I was
trying to really make the most out of
this I would try to create some type of
um you know user interface or button or
something that I can use on like the
side over here that would integrate
maybe like a widget or something this
just you know isn't great and this is
what most people are going to do this is
what I tried to do when I was first
doing it and if you're having trouble
you may need to do pip install open AI
in your anaconda prompt if you're using
it through Anaconda that's where I'm
using it through so just pip install it
installs it and then of course you can
use this exact code right here again
don't really recommend it it's honestly
not that great but this is how you do it
now when I was going through all the
research to find this I found this right
here this is the chap gbt Jupiter AI
assistant it is super great and I found
this and I was like hey I need to make a
video on this not for anything more than
to just show it to you in case you use
jupyter notebooks in your work this is a
fantastic integration and they even have
all of the um code for it in their
GitHub so you can go and you can
literally clone this and create your own
if you want to with any extra code you
would like to do but uh you know he
walks through how he created it what it
does everything in here now really
quickly I'm just going to give you a
quick demonstration of how it works but
when you install it you come right here
you I've already installed it but you
just select you know install or download
then you refresh your jupyter notebook
and then you get all these buttons up
here buttons like format explain debug
complete
review
question and then there is a voice
question now all of these other
functions are completely free but if you
go to the very bottom right here it says
that the voice command you can ask it
questions this part does cost money
actually it talks about how much it
costs right down right up here actually
is the voice command so it uses the
whisper API and charges .006 per minute
so if if you do use that that costs
money but everything else is completely
free which is just uh it's fantastic so
if we go back here let's go down and
let's say I have this error right here
for example I can come in here and I can
click debug and if I click debug right
at the bottom it starts prompting or
creating this output for us it's only at
the very bottom but it even says look
there's an issue with your code it looks
like you needed a semicolon or a colon
so it corrects the code and you can just
copy that which is fantastic or you can
come right over here and click copy and
you can then paste it into here and
it'll work better and actually that's an
issue because I need to get rid of this
there we go so that's how they get
around that now it's free because
they're using the chat GPD 3.5 they're
not using the Chachi bg4 which would
cost you money and I believe you can
actually upgrade that as well when
you're actually adding this you do need
an API key in order to use this you just
have to input it in case you do use the
whisper API then it charges you but I've
been using this quite a bit just testing
it out running a bunch of you know tests
and different stuff and it's been
working perfectly uh let's go back up
really quickly and let me get rid of
this
I'm zoomed in let me get rid of this
and let's say I want to do something
like format or
um let me do the complete so I'll just
do this right here and let's say
I wanted to do num
times I'm just going to get rid of this
and then we'll do complete so now it's
going to say num2 and it's even going to
give us different stuff so it's going to
do a list comprehension so we didn't say
do numb to the power of two but you know
I think it saw our last
we're right here and it's going to work
perfect so we're just going to copy this
and we're going to paste it down here
and if we run this you know it gives us
an output so it changed this which
basically is nothing this is hot garbage
and it changes it into a nice little you
know query for whatever you're using for
as you get more complex of course it's
going to be more tough and it's going to
have you know different options and it
may get things wrong but this is exactly
working off what you would have gotten
if you just plug this into the chat GPT
um you know window or their website so I
thought this was just really really cool
and if I click on this I can even go
over here I Gotta Have It explain it to
me so now it's going to explain this
code to me all within my browser which
again I just really like and it keeps it
super simple so you know they're using
it using list comprehension squared list
and element so it just explains the code
to you now this isn't a full tutorial on
how to use this so I'm not going to show
you every single thing I just wanted to
show you how you can use the API key how
it's not super useful and this extension
that I found that I've been using for a
little while and it's been working
awesome so I wanted to show this to you
thought it would be helpful thought it
would be useful if you were interested
in this I'm going to leave links to
basically all of these in the
description to where you can access your
API key to the GitHub with this code
that I don't really recommend to this
extension and this GitHub repo as well
so I hope that this was helpful if you
use jupyter notebooks I highly recommend
downloading this extension it's just
super cool if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign